nick is with us nick is in ohio hi Nick
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thanks for taking my call
I'm sure man what's up hey question if
we're my wife and I are 34 and 35 and we
are baby step 7
awesome recently received a $40,000
inheritance my grandparents passed away
Wow they did a lot of data a lot of
traveling and we want to use it as a
travel
investment for us so we would be able to
utilize whatever the game was on the
year we would use that for traveling is
there an investment product we can use
to invest in or is it does it make sense
to do that or just kind of use you take
that 40,000 and just work it down or we
don't try to keep that nest egg if at
all possible yeah that's pretty cool I
like your idea and congratulations man
you're killing it what's your house
worth about 250,000 Wow and you're 35
years old and you're already on
completely debt-free and investing yes
sorry about $600,000 and and as a
network so you're almost there you're
almost everyday millionaires already
anything to you wow I didn't give you
any money you did it man where'd it go
I'm proud of you all right yeah I like
your idea I would just use a an S&P 500
fund that's no Commission no load and
the reason is it's low turnover ratio
means that there won't be any taxes on
it except when you pull money out of it
and if you leave it in there at least a
year before you pull money out of it
then you would have only capital gains
tax on whatever you pull out okay
now you won't have any tax on the forty
thousand the forty thousand but but
let's say that thing goes up five
thousand bucks one year and you don't
pull the money out when you do get
around to pulling it out if you've left
it in there at least a year the gains
then you will have you will not pay
ordinary income on it you'll only pay
fifteen percent tax okay and so and it
should grow you know ten twelve percent
a year that's what the you know the
stock market is done some years it'll do
better some years it'll be worse but if
you can make for five grand on that
thing that's a triple year right yeah
exactly
makes two thousand or two thousand trip
forest I thought if I thought trip to
try to mean it goes down that year you
stay home exactly right or you buy or
you pack or you pay for your trip out of
your other fun but you don't mess with
this thing yes exactly right I love this
plan yeah that's cool that's fun I like
their smiling when you do it because
they like to travel I like it very cool
yeah just an S&P 500 somebody like
fidelity or Vanguard vanguards got one
that's excellent
but they're all they're all should be
very very similar I have very low
turnover ratio have very low fees and no
commissions there are no loads and so
they're perfect for something like this
because again you know it sets it up to
where if you leave the gain alone for a
year then it is gonna be taxed at only
15% which is so wheat I like it yeah
your run around acting like rich people
look at you I love it you are that's
awesome I'm proud of you so those of you
that you people say oh right people are
evil so that 35 year old guy who paid
off his house and has sage $600,000 in
its 401k and is improperly investing a
forty thousand dollar inheritance in
order to go travel off of the income
only that the inheritance makes he's
evil what's wrong with you you think
that guy's evil rich people are all evil
they'll rip somebody off it ripping buy
off he just planted corn and corn grew
he just did we supposed to do and some
of you have the audacity to walk around
in your socialist victim mentalities and
say that guy's evil all rich people are
evil you ought to be ashamed of yourself
you ought to be ashamed of yourself Dave
you're shaming me yes I am you ought to
be ashamed of yourself
it's a ridiculous sentiment 11 mil
millionaires in North America ten
million of them are first-generation
rich they're that guy when you call rich
people evil what you're really saying is
I'm jealous what you're really saying is
I'm a small-minded bozo
that's what you're really saying because
you feel trapped and you feel the
inability to control your own self and
so you have to drag other people down
because you're out of control
well there's a different way of looking
at things who is this crazy hillbilly
well it's called the Dave Ramsey show
and 17 million of you tuned in every day
and we appreciate you every single one
of you well most of you this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]